hello there you're watching the press
preview first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and in the
next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and author rachel
shavi
and the leader writer for the daily
telegraph tim stanley
welcome both of you thanks so much for
joining us on this saturday evening
let's take a look then and see what's on
the front of a lot of those papers
well the prime minister is under
mounting pressure to rethink plans
to relax covert rules on monday due to
the threat posed by the indian variant
the telegraph reports that the
government aimed to vaccinate one
million people a day
in efforts to beat the indian variant of
covert 19
could save the summer that story is also
on the front page of the sunday express
serial killer rose west's daughter has
told the sunday mirror that her mother
is the key to unlocking the
circumstances
surrounding the disappearance of mary
bastone believed to be one of fred
west's victims
footballer marcus rashford has broken up
with his childhood sweetheart according
to the sun
and in anticipation of the relaxation of
coronavirus restrictions next week the
star has turned to
starsky and hutch star huggy bear just
in case you've forgotten
how to hug
perish the thought we're joined tonight
by rachel shabby and
tim stanley um uh thanks again for
for joining us guys and the observers
we're going to kick off with
rachel um boris johnson must think again
on plans to relax
covert rules a certain amount of
pressure that he's facing
uh in questions about whether or not the
timing is right to start
relaxing the regulations
well that's right it seems that his own
scientific advisors are concerned about
the relaxation of um lockdown
restrictions that we're going to see
on monday it seems that their particular
concern
is the easing of restrictions around
pubs
and they worry that young people in
particular
will be vulnerable to a surge
in infections and consequently a surge
in hospital cases and hospitals being
overwhelmed in the way that we saw
earlier this year much of this is to do
with concerns over the india variant and
it's now
known that 20 000 passengers came
from india to the uk uh in that period
when boris johnson delayed putting india
on that red list that travel ban
it now seems that he uh was delaying
that because he wanted to go and
visit india to see narendra modi prime
minister
to talk about a deal so a trade deal
that
he thinks that the uk needs after brexit
and that was what the delay was about
but it seems that his advisers are
saying
to him uh you know this the the idea of
pubs reopening is perhaps not a good
idea
and they want to see your restrictions
they're particularly worried about
the region of the northwest and they
want to see restrictions
maintained either in that region
specifically
or just nationwide uh for at least
another month
and tim in the sunday telegraph uh we're
hearing from some conservative mps steve
baker
um so the pressure is on the prime
minister from within his own camp
to reconsider uh about about the speed
of the relaxations
boris johnson said on friday that
because of the emergence of the indian
variant
there's a possibility that the race
between britain vaccinating
and the spread of the virus might begin
to tighten
now there are two logical responses to
that
one as the observer reports as some
scientific advisors are saying
one is to slow the rate at which you
unlock to keep certain restrictions in
place
possibly even have local lockdowns like
we experimented with
late last year the other logical step
is to intensify your vaccination program
so that even as the indian variance
spreads because we are vaccinating much
larger numbers of people at a much
faster rate we stay
one step ahead of it um now the
government
is hoping that at some point it'll hit a
target of vaccinating one million people
a day not impossible a few days ago
germany uh carried pulled off a european
record by vaccinating 1.1 million people
in one day
and the government seems to believe it
has the stockpiles to do it
this itself raises other strategic
questions one is
who do you rush to vaccinate do you
rush to get out the second dose for
older people who've had the first dose
or do you start to concentrate doses on
younger people
which seems to be the cohort among which
the indian
variant is spreading so there's going to
be a big debate in the next few days as
we open up on monday
do we slow down unlocking do we
intensify vaccinations
do we do both but either way the indian
variant
has definitely forced the government to
have a big conversation about the way
waveform
and on the front of the sunday express
rachel
it says it in massive font which to me
shouts
panic it says we can't afford to panic
do you think there is a fear that we
will panic
it's a somewhat self-defeating panicked
headline isn't it i think you're right
about that
um look there's a difference between
panic and
just being sensible and cautious you
know
to me it makes sense to be more cautious
in the
short term so that you know we can ease
up
properly in the long term uh i feel
for myself personally i would rather
delay restrictions easing
for a few weeks now if it means that we
can absolutely get on top of this
situation
um in a few months down the line so i do
i do think that
you know that it's not necessarily a
particularly helpful
headline um and there i think there are
still plenty of reasons to be cautious
we might find that sort of percolating
among the population but also
you know we do need to keep talking
about the government being
late to respond to things it's
incredible to me that
this far into the pandemic it's still
responding too late and too slow
to advice from its own scientists but
also we need to be looking at
if we are easing lockdown restrictions
we definitely need to ramp up test and
trace again
billions spent on that to private
contractors who are not up to the job
the tracing element particularly
is not working in the way that it should
and people are not being given the
financial means to isolate
if they need to so those elements are
still
not in place a year down the line and
you have to wonder
why not because these are the sort of
things that gonna allow us
to ease restrictions in the way that we
all want to do you think that's a fair
comment tim
that actually you know if people are
concerned about
putting bread on the table that they are
going to be a lot more reluctant to to
have tests if they think they could
potentially be at risk or indeed report
them if they have any symptoms
oh sure i think there's always been a
risk of that i would say stick to the
timetable as much as possible
partly for the economic reasons and also
there's the welfare reasons of people
getting psychologically used to things
unlocking and it would be a tremendous
shock if they didn't unlock
but also there are many businesses right
now which really are on a knife edge
they've not been functioning at full
capacity from monday they can move
towards doing that we're not just
talking restaurants and bars on monday
you will see
cinemas and theaters reopen and the idea
that those might have to shut would just
be absolutely devastating
there is a cost to lock down there is
obviously a cost of the pandemic
spreading no one's denying that of
course there is it's
it's measured in mortality but there is
also a human and economic cost
uh to sustain the lockdown for much
longer plus there is alternative
economic
also so there is alternative scientific
advice there are some scientists who are
saying don't panic
partly because the indian variant it
looks like does spread faster
but there isn't yet a proven link
between that faster spread and a rise in
hospitalizations
and that's what really matters it is
possible this is a
this is looking at on the brighter side
it is possible that a fast spread among
young people
is a sign of the success of the
vaccination program
that sufficient numbers of older people
have been vaccinated that they're not
catching this thing
and although young people can suffer
from covet 19 of course they can
they are much less likely to suffer from
it much less likely to end up in
hospital
so there is an argument against
overreacting
and against extending lockdown and the
prime minister's got to weigh up those
two different set those two different
sources of advice
and i i personally if i was speaking to
him would say do your damn best to stick
to the
june deadline because the country really
wants to reopen
and i think it's time it started let's
move away from kovid
and on to another story which also has
an enormous human and economic cost
um and rachel is on the front of the
observer marked in a lot of the other
papers what's going on
between the israelis and the
palestinians at the moment um
it's it's distressing on all sides isn't
it
it's absolutely distressing and
heartbreaking to see the situation
there's been protests around the world
um in outrage
uh israel's um assaults on gaza 150 000
people
in london alone but that has been
happening globally
um and of course it's there is just no
justification
for the terrorizing assault
being carried out on gaza right now we
have to remember that gaza is sealed off
uh there is a population of two million
two million people
um under siege uh there is
nowhere for them to go gaza is sealed
off so they are
sitting targets um and today alone
um israeli forces have attacked a
refugee camp
um they've killed eight cousins from the
same family
who children who were just celebrating
either
the holiday tomorrow the end of ramadan
and it has also struck a building
containing
both al jazeera english and associated
press which obviously is absolutely uh
something that we should all be united
in condemning
um an attack on international media
um so it's it's very distressing to
watch these
images and we just have to keep in mind
that this is completely
disproportionate use of force against a
population that doesn't have an army
they don't have a navy they don't have
an air force
they have no way of defending themselves
no shelter
no iron dome um they are sitting targets
and they are currently being terrorized
however
rachel those living inside israel who
have also been the subject of bomb
attacks coming from
hamas rockets coming from gaza up to up
to the tel aviv area and we know that
there haven't been as many deaths but
there have been
a handful of deaths on the israeli side
and
will say that they too are living in
terror
and tim one element of what seems to
have changed over the last few days is
that
that it's actually people inside israel
arab israelis and
arab jews who are also now fighting and
that that is an incredibly worrying
development isn't it that that it seems
to be pitting communities that
that were living side by side in
relative harmony
against each other yes which poses
difficult questions about the future of
israel and
what and how and whether or not it can
prosper in its current state
i mean you you've put it very well
rachel has uh
very articulately and convincingly uh
explain what's happened to the people of
gaza but you're right to provide some
balance and say there has also been over
2 000 rockets fired from the guard from
gaza
into israel and if israel did not have
the iron dome protecting its civilians
um i'm sure many more hundreds of
israelis would have died as well
i always feel like a complete chump
saying it's a complicated situation
because that sounds like i'm i'm dodging
the moral responsibility to say
what can be done or what should be done
but the reality it is complicated it's
made even more complicated by local
politics
by hamas struggling for control over the
palestinian people with fatah
there was supposed to be some elections
that are cancelled them
that might be one motivating factor for
hamas to behave in this way
it also has links to iran which are very
troubling likewise within
israel netanyahu was in trouble before
this crisis
and this crisis strengthens his position
politically so what that all amounts to
is it's very difficult to see
where those who are currently in charge
and claim to speak
for either side where they will give
ground
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now rachel shabby and
tim
stanley um and the telegraph has a story
on its front page tim
about um museum board seats that they're
gonna start handing them over to well
they're describing them as red wall
voters
uh essentially that they're suggesting
that that
gruff northerners will be less woke than
the uh than the metropolitan elites that
many museums have on their boards
but they they may very well have a point
uh the the government
is going ahead with its culture war it's
not backing down this stuff and oliver
doubt and the cultural secretary
has said that as as you've described it
uh museums and other trusts must have a
greater national representation on their
boards um
not just for the sake of diversity and
representation but also because they
think it means that
those sorts of people will say no to
political fads like taking down statues
or renaming things
another critical element of the story by
the way and i quote it here is
robert generic the community secretary
will amend building regulations so that
buildings used by the public
must have separate ladies and gents
lavatories in the future
and that's quite a significant
development actually again culture war
stuff
governments taking a stance against uh
unisex toilets there
is going to ensure that in the future
public buildings will have to provide
uh facilities separately for men and
women very interesting
uh rachel we literally have 10 seconds
but uh why should we be referring to
starsky and hutch over the next few days
uh
because they think that we the star the
daily star thinks we've forgotten how to
hug
so it's brought out puggy bear from star
trek disgusting hutch to remind us but
um
i don't think we have really i think we
got a sort of muscle memory
of how hugging works i think we're going
to be fine and we also have an excuse to
not hug people we don't particularly
want to
uh rachel and tim thank you both so much
i will get a lot more from you in half
an hour thank you very much